This morning, a
blockbuster shake up in the world
of artificial intelligence.
Just days after a year
after he was ousted by the company
he co-founded, former OpenAI CEO
Sam Altman is joining Microsoft
and so is another open A.I.
co-founder, Greg Brockman.
The two men who helped bring chat to
the world's
will lead Microsoft's new advanced A.I.
research team.
So there's been a lot going on.
That's why I got CNN's Vanessa Jurkovich.
She's here with us now.
All right, Vanessa
look,
there are ongoing negotiations
for Altman to return as open air CEO.
Then he goes to Microsoft.
What's been happening here?
I don't think that GPT
could have written this drama
This has been a lot in 72 hours.
So the breaking news that we have now
is that 500 employees from open air.
I have sent this letter to the board,
which ousted Sam Altman,
saying that if you do not resign,
if you do not bring back Sam
Altman, we will quit
and we will join Sam Altman at Microsoft.
505 employees at most of the company.
But this all goes down on Friday
when open.
OpenAI basically pushes Sam
Altman out the board, saying
that he's not equipped
to lead the company right now.
He hasn't been very transparent.
Behind the scenes, though,
what we know
is that there's a
philosophical difference
between Altman wanting to push forward
and the board
who wants to kind of dial
the progress of A.I. back.
But what we know is that many employees
have already followed Altman,
including his co-founder Greg Brockman.
Over the weekend,
we saw a photo of Altman
at a eye opening,
opening its offices,
maybe talks of bringing him back again.
That did not happen.
That's where you enter micro soft.
They have invested $13 billion
into open air.
They own 49% of the company.
Just this morning,
we're hearing that
they have hired Altman to now run
artificial intelligence at Microsoft.
And just moments ago,
we heard from one of the board members
who was part of that four person board
that fired Altman.
And he says
he actually regrets
the fact
that he's created all this chaos at open
A.I..
He's also
one of the more than 500 people
who has signed this open letter
calling for the board to resign,
which means including himself.
This all matters
because artificial intelligence is here.
It is the future.
There are serious conversations
about whether or not it's moving
too fast.
Can it be weaponized?
What does it mean for all of us?
There are so many businesses
that rely on GPT every single day.
I just want to read a quick quote
from an analyst, Dan Ivers,
who puts this perfectly.
I think he says in a nutshell, the J.V.
four person board at OpenAI.
I was at the kid's poker table
and they thought they won
until Nadella and Microsoft
took this all over in a World Series
game of poker
move for the ages
with the Valley and Wall Street watching.
This is going to continue
to unfold over today,
but just so much in 72 hours
changing the game of A.I.
So much has happened
and I'm sure so much more.
We'll have to see your cave.
Thank you so much.
That is Stewart joins me from London.
I don't honestly
I mean, the fallout from the board
decision could not be more consequential.
Some 500 of the 700 employees
threatening to quit the company.
Just explain what's going on here
and why
this weekend's news was so significant.
It is hard to keep up with what has been
one of the most spectacular
corporate fallouts.
I think I can remember
really in terms of a board firing a CEO
very suddenly,
seeing the fallout from investors,
but also within the company.
And this is just the latest.
This is a letter
to the board of directors of OpenAI.
As you mentioned, over
500 employees have agreed to this.
And when I say it's the letter
to the board of directors, Becky,
there were six directors as of last week.
One was fired.
Sam Altman,
the other co-founder,
Greg Brockman, actually
resigned on the basis of this news.
And a third
is actually signing this letter.
So it was almost a letter to themselves
at this stage,
which means
there are
three directors are
being very much targeted by this letter.
And I'll just highlight
a few bits
that we've had in the last hour.
It says
they believe the board
is incapable of overseeing open air.
They say they may choose to resign
and join Microsoft with Sam
Altman and Greg Brockman,
join that new entity. They be in a show.
They have positions.
And these are there times
they say
they will take this step
imminently unless all current
board members resign.
That's the three I mentioned.
And the board appoints two new lead
independent directors.
They mentioned a couple
and reinstate
Sam Altman and Greg Brockman.
So that is the most extraordinary laying
down of the law from over 500 employees.
The CTO and a board member
on that as well.
So now you have to
wonder, is the Microsoft move
going to happen
or are we going to see a complete
rejig again at the top?
And are we going to see Sam Altman, Greg
Brockman, going back to open? I
just remind
you, Sam,
always to those who you know
is you on in the kind of,
you know, in the weeds of A.I., they
they may not know who he is.
This guy is a very, very,
very significant player,
not just in business,
but in US
and global politics these days as well.
He's become the biggest voice really,
when we talk about
artificial intelligence.
He's the loudest voice at least.
They're all just
a handful of companies really
running the AI debate,
I guess,
in terms of a few companies
that lead the way
there's Google
DeepMind with them as Hassabis
and the Sam Altman with Open Mind.
He is the biggest voice.
He's one of the co-founders
of the company.
There are quite a few co-founders there,
but he's become very vocal
and very eloquent, particularly,
as you mentioned, at Senate
committee hearings
and the political level.
You see him on the international stage,
and he's very vocal on Twitter.
And one of the big questions
for all of us, right on Friday was
why has he been fired from the board?
And there's lots of speculation
about this from the company.
We actually didn't get very much
there was something about
a lack of communication with the board,
but no more detail.
Other people wonder
whether his popularity
had eclipsed the board,
and therefore,
frankly, they lost control of what
some of them
wanted to do with the company
or whether his part in terms
of trying to commercialize
the profit part of OpenAI,
because it is a nonprofit
entity generally,
whether they felt
that was undermining or
risking air safety
Where's he going?
Well, he signed up for Microsoft,
but as of the last hour,
this letter from over 500
employees demanding
he goes back to open air.
You have to wonder, Becky,
check back next hour.
Good stuff.
Thanks.